[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه تماما مثل ملف الغذاء الذي تنظر
الدول في كيفيه التحكم في برامجه بتخزين
كميه منه ينبغي عليها النظر الى الانترنت
وخطوط النطاق العريض بمثل هذه المقاربه
الاستراتيجيه
ينبغي لها النظر في خطط تمكنها من التاكد
من نفاذ مواطنيها الى هذه الخدمه الحيويه
في حال النزاعات ومهما كانت الظروف فمن
ناحيه الانفاق على هذا الامر فهو بكل
تاكيدا لا يتكلف الكثير ولكنه من الناحيه
الحيويه مهم جدا لبقاء الدول والمحافظه
على متطلبات العيش بين مواطنيها وايضا
بينها وبين باقي العالم في عالم اليوم
يمكن للفرد ان لا يتناول وجبه غذاء مقابل
عدم التنازلي عن لحظه على الانترنت لذلك
فقد بات هذا الامر مهما جدا ويحظى
بالاولويه المطلقه لدى الحكومات التي
يتعين عليها التحرك بقوه على هذا الصعيد
اعتقد اننا بلغنا بالفعل نقطه اللعوده
التي من غير الممكن فيها تقريبا ان يتم
بناء خط من دون مشاركه واحده من شركات
عمالقه التكنولوجيا الاربعه عمليا وحتى
بحكم الامر الواقع اصبح ذلك في حكم صعب
جدا واعتقد انه بات لزاما على الحكومات
الانخراط منذ الان وعدم اهدار الوقت في
هذا الملف للعب الدور الذي تكون فيه
بمثابه المنطقه العازله التي تبدا الشركات
ببناء خطوتها ليس داخلها وانما بعد حدودها